chartres avenue jean mermoz c'est là que
sera jugée l'arrivée de la 7e étape du
tour de france
on va sur la portion plate pour les 200
derniers mètres veulent les 200 derniers
mais qui restent les jeunes du vélo
sport chartreux en reconnaissance ils
franchiront la ligne quelques heures
avant les pros sont hyper content c'est
quand même une récompense parce que là
moi j'ai su il ya deux trois mois de ça
qu on allait participer et faire les
deux derniers kilomètres donc les jeunes
le mercredi à l'entraînement était hyper
motivés de désir qui vont effectuer les
deux derniers kilomètres balisés ils
vont certainement se faire applaudir par
les spectateurs lors du dernier passage
du tour à chartres en 2012 il n'y avait
pas d'écoles de cyclisme c'est donc une
grande première pour le club les enfants
espère avoir l'occasion d'approcher les
champions dans ce petit peloton
les sprinteurs ont la cote je leur ai
philippe en antarctique peter sagan
champion du monde grand gagnant du
sondage les français sont également bien
placées julian alaphilippe formé à
saint-amand-montrond et romain bardet
sont souvent dans le haut de classement
ou continue notre tour
les recourants préféré dix mois warren
d'ariel warren barguil peter sagan peter
sagan peter sagan et un nicolas aider
nicolas aider le plus heureux liens des
sarthois il est arrivé au club de
chartres lorsqu'il était cadet il y est
toujours licencié et maintenant le
parrain de l'école de cyclisme
les jeunes espère le retrouver à
l'arrivée avec le reste du peloton
nicolas aider mark cavendish nicolas et
des orane barguil allait filer en
embardée
bob jungels vous les amoureux du vélo
qui allait venir très tôt applaudir les
professionnels n'hésitez pas à
encourager aussi ces jeunes que vous
retrouverez peut-être parmi les grands
du tour d'ici quelques années
le cyclisme est en fête
[Musique]